si la contre-offensive ukrainienne a
pris de courts les troupes russes
l'étendue de son succès à tout autant
surpris ses soldats Ukrainiens
on l'a occupé et on l'a fortifié trois
jours plus tard le front a avancé ils
ont commencé à partir en masse on se
tenait prêt à combattre alors imaginez
qu'ils allaient quitter l'ensemble du
front ça vraiment on ne l'avait pas
prévu
des soldats s'affairent à remettre en
marche le matériel abandonné par
l'ennemi
des vis un peu par là ça va aller pour
le roulement
c'est la nouvelle génération de
véhicules Oural russe qu'ils avaient
préparé pour l'invasion
et bien maintenant ils vont travailler
pour nous
la déroute de l'armée russe se constate
partout
ces hommes tout juste arrivé pour
sécuriser le territoire découvre les
anciennes positions ennemis ce sont des
caisses de munitions des requêtes BM 21
gratuit je me trompe pas
les lignes Russes se sont disloquées
ici ne reste plus que Lénine une pin-up
et des journaux de style soviétique sans
mauvaise nouvelle
l'histoire de ce succès tactique tient
en partie à la ruse utilisée par le
commandement ukrainien quelques semaines
avant la contre-offensive
c'est ce que révèle André malakofficier
des forces spéciales ukrainiennes il a
été blessé par balle pendant l'opération
j'ai dirigé l'assaut ma manœuvre
principale était la diversion au sud de
ballakiya
en fait
la plus grosse percée s'est faite par
l'ouest mais leur enseignement a répondu
partout l'information que l'attaque
aurait lieu au sud ils ont donc envoyé
beaucoup de troupes au sud et quand
l'assaut a commencé on en a tué 200
toutes leurs tentative de contre-atta
ont été repoussés ils s'en souviendront
longtemps
un succès d'autant plus rare que ces
troupes étaient trois fois moins
nombreuses que celles des Russes